Starting from the bottom, if I remove the last line,
we never actually call mistletoe, so our program just declares a variable,
declares a function, and then exits,
so we don't see the exception.
So we can't remove this line.
Let's take a look up here.
What if I comment out baldr is baldr + 1?
Well, with our bug in environment lookup, this line a gets a + 2
will still cause us to die.
So we can remove baldr is baldr + 1 and still see the exception.
How about this one?
If I remove a is a + 2, we'll still see the exception down here
in baldr is baldr + a.
We'll look up the value of a and not find it. So I can remove that line.
Similarly, if I remove this third line, we can still die on line 2.
So now, potentially, we have a lot of information available to us.
We know that we need to make this call,
we know that these 3 lines are important,
and in a more fully formed integrated development environment
or interpreter like the Python interpreter, we'd get an exception backtrace
that would point us to this line
or, if we've commented out that line, point us to the next one.
So with all of this information, we get a better feel for what's actually required.